STARTS ON RIGHT WING FOR LOS
ANGELES.
MILLER CONTROLS OFF THE ANDERSO,
AND NIC CREASE.
CHIASSON'S ABLE TO CLEAR IT TO
PLAY'S ALLOWED TO CONTINUE AND
HUGHES LEFT CORNER
COULDN'T FIND THE TARGET.RAFT.
DOWN LOW WITH GRUNDSTROMLEMIEUXS
EKMAN-LARSSON OFF THE GLASS.
OFF,
AROUND EKMAN-LARSSON, DROPS IT
TO BROWN W DEEP THOUGH.
HERE'S THE TOP LINE OF THE KINGS
AGAIN.
TO
DRAW.
BLAKE LIZOTTE KUPARI.
TO THE RIGHT SIDE, THROWN TO THE
GOAL BY DUSTIN BROWN.
GOAL.
CHIASSON TAKEN INTO THE WALL BY
SHOT.
I THINK IT GOT THROUGH ON
PETERSEN.
MADE A B
BOESER THROUGH THE CENTRE ICE
CIRCLE FOR PODKOLZIN, DRIVING
WIDE ON THE LEFT WING INTO THE O
MILLER WHO'S KNOCKED FOR
JORDAN SPENCE. WIN IN SEATTLE LT
NIGHT, AND JUST TAKES THIS SHOT,
FORCED TO THE CORNER BY DESPERAL
PETERSEN.
BEAUTIFUL PASS BY ELIAS
AND THE KINGS WILL SET UP THEIR
AND HERE COMES THE SHOLIZOTTE, M
TO PETTERSSON RIGHT CIRCLOR MILT
WING.
WANTED TO
MILLER, NEAR CIRCLE. GETS IN TH.
HUGHES SPIN-O-RAMA, AWAY FROM
VILARDI, SHOT TIPPED,
MOVE.
INSIDE OUTSIDE, VILARDI
COMPLETELY FOOLED BY IT, THE NOD
INSTEAD. COME THE KINGS
TWO-ON-ONE.
ATHANASIOU TO LIZIS OWN
END.
NOW CONSTITUENT BEHIND THE WING,
BLOCKED AGAIN, HE SCORES!
[ Cheering ]
[ Horn Blaring ]